Text on screen: Vera Institute of Justice
Vera Voices Podcast Series
Neil A. Weiner, Research Speaker Series, presents: David Weisburd, PhD, Distinguished Professor George Mason University
and Director, Institute of Criminology, The Hebrew University
Hot Spots of Crime and Crime Prevention with David Weisburd, PhD,
Distinguished Professor George Mason University and Director, Institute of Criminology, The Hebrew University
Hot spots of crime are a new unit of analysis, if you like,
in trying to understand crime problems and do something about them.
Most of the time criminologists or crime prevention specialists have thought about doing something about the crime problem,
they focus on two units: one, either the individual.
Most of what we do about the crime problem, up to now at least, has been focused on individuals;
how we can stop them from recidivating.
But also on large macrounits of geography, like communities or neighborhoods or beats or precincts.
Hot spots of crime refers to something very different, on a much smaller microgeographic level.
A hot spot can be a single street segment. It could be a small group of street segments.
But still very much smaller, in geographic terms, than traditional units of "places," if you like,
that have interested criminologists or others concerned about the crime problem.
The question of why they're important, one simple way of saying that,
is that we looked at the distribution of crime across geography.
We've found that crime is extraordinarily concentrated at small, microgeographic hot spots.
For example, in Seattle, Washington, over a 14-year period, for every year,
50 percent of the crime is found at less than 5 percent of the street segments in the city.
These findings have been replicated in a whole series of studies.
Crime is very concentrated at place.
Also in Seattle, 86 street segments out of almost 30,000 have about a third of all juvenile crime incidents.
Well, this concentration of crime at these hot spots presents a great advantage.
We can deal with a lot of crime by dealing with a relatively few places in the city.
The question of why we should put more emphasis on crime hot spots has to do, in part,
with the issue of concentration that I noted already.
If a lot of crime is concentrated at a very small group of places,
we can have a big effect on the crime problem by concentrating on those places.
But it's not just that crime is concentrated at a small number of places.
When we look at the data, we find that crime is relatively stable over time at those places.
Now, compare that to individual offending, where we know that people start out in their mid-teens and late teens,
committing crimes, then they go to relatively large rates of criminal activity in their early 20s.
And then they start to age out of crime.
So, crime is relatively unstable across the life course for individuals.
We've looked at 14 years of data in Seattle, and what we've found is that 1 percent of the street segments
produce about 23 percent of the crime, and they stay hot throughout that period.
So, they're chronic hot spots. They're stable.
Now, I should note as well that these hot spots have characteristics that make them hot.
There are reasons why crime comes to those places.
Sometimes it's because it's a place where they; with a train stop or a bus stop
or other places where people are getting on and off with lots of victims around.
We've found that, for example, where there are large groups of employees on a block there tends to be more crime.
Well, that also means we have a sense of why crime is occurring there,
but we can also try to develop strategies to do something about it.
There is a series of studies, many of them randomized experiments,
that show that if the police focus on crime hot spots, that crime will go down in those places.
Now, the simplest response to that is often,
"Well, they might go down there, but won't you just push crime around the corner?"
Well, interestingly enough, the evidence we have says that's not gonna happen.
At least, you're not gonna have enough crime pushed around the corner
to make the crime prevention efforts carried out at those places not worthwhile.
In that group of studies that we know of, in which police have concentrated on crime hot spots,
we found not only that crime goes down at the hot spots,
but when the crime does change in the areas immediately surrounding, it doesn't go up. It goes down.
In other words, you don't have displacement of crime; you have what we call a diffusion of crime control benefits.
In other words, if you crack down on hot spots, more likely than not, the areas around the hot spots will get better.
Well, if that's the case, then certainly hot spots policing makes very good sense.
This is a strategy that can work, and can work without displacement.
And that's why the National Academy of Sciences, in their report on police practices and policies,
concluded that the strongest evidence we have about effective policing is about hot spots policing.
Up till now, most of the approaches that we've brought against hot spots have been law enforcement approaches
in which the police and police strategies have predominated.
But work we've been doing suggests that maybe we ought to think a bit more broadly.
We've looked at the causes of criminal activity at these hot spots.
We often find that there are, let's call them social causes.
Or, at least they're causes that can be addressed not only by the police and;
but also by other criminal justice agencies and, perhaps, non-criminal justice agencies.
We've found that social characteristics of places
(poverty, elements of young people hanging out in the streets, etcetera)
that those have a strong effect on whether a place is a crime hot spot.
I think we might want to think in the long term about how we can change these small places
so that the social features are less conducive to crime, including poverty, including family issues, children, etcetera.
I would say that the importance of this, and the importance of hot spots here, is that, for the most part,
crime prevention specialists have said, "We can't do something about poverty in the whole city.
We can't change the nature of juvenile activities in the whole city."
But you know what? If there's a relatively small group of places that are hot spots, maybe we can change those places.
And maybe by changing those places, we can do something about the crime problem.
And if we take those kinds of approaches, by the way, we'll also do something else very important.
We imprison an enormous number of people in the United States.
Imprisonment comes from law enforcement.
When the police are around, one of the things they might do is arrest people.
They have a tendency towards law enforcement.
With that in mind, to the extent that we can deal with these hot spots without law enforcement,
we can get crime prevention benefits without the disabilities or the problems associated with arrest and imprisonment.
Vera Institute of Justice, Vera Voices Podcast Series
Neil A. Weiner, Research Speaker Series, presents: David Weisburd, PhD, Distinguished Professor George Mason University and Director, Institute of Criminology, The Hebrew University
www.vera.org, Research Department, www.vera.org/research